when william thomas the hulking dude who
beat all the chicks at the ncaa swim and
dive championship a couple of weeks ago
when he won
one quote unquote
it became quite clear from the pictures
of that event that he's a man he's tall
he's heavy he's got broad shoulders he's
got a big adam's apple he has other
protrusions that were clear in his borat
jumpsuit he hasn't changed a thing about
his body he's not this is why part of me
thinks he might be just a performance
artist showing the absurdity of gender
theory because he just
clearly looks like a man he hasn't
changed his voice the only thing he did
was slightly grow his hair out and then
he put a swim cap on so that didn't even
matter
and the reporting from the establishment
media couldn't bear that
it was too real people would just see
they say wait a second i read in the
newspaper i heard on television
that this man was a demure delicate
little woman
but actually you look at him he's
obviously just a dude he's towering over
these girls so what did nbc news do
when they had a choice between changing
their reporting
and changing the reality of the story
itself what do you think they chose you
know what they chose they tried to
change the reality nbc news the today
show got in a lot of trouble because
they took an image of will thomas
and totally airbrushed it out so all of
the features on thomas that seemed
masculine on this is just his face uh
his shoulders were even were kind of in
the water so it's really just the face
they just softened all of the features
to make him look more like a woman it
was a really bad
airbrushing job it was a really bad
photoshop job
thankfully thankfully the editors at nbc
are so incompetent that they couldn't do
a good job at it let me tell you if they
had daily wire editors here they would
have it would have been much more
persuasive okay but they've only got
incompetence over there at nbc so it
didn't work you looked at it you said
wait a second that's not
why is it why is it so smooth why is the
lighting like oh because when you look
at the real photo he's obviously a dude
so they have to lie they have to lie
every step of the way they have to lie
in their laws and regulations they've
got to lie in their corporate policies
they've got to lie in photographs okay
because they are so
dead set
on
manufacturing this delusion that we're
all going to live in
this is
this is
not a coincidence that we're dealing
with this insane
biological anti-biological ideology at
the same time that we're seeing a major
technological revolution that confuses
reality we've got deep fakes we've got
very high-end video technology we're now
moving into virtual reality in the
metaverse and what the the push is here
for the left is to just reimagine
reality it goes all the way back to one
of john f kennedy's favorite lines which
he stole from george bernard shaw the
socialist playwright who put the words
in the mouth of the serpent in the
garden of eden tempting eve who said
some people see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say why not
this line which the left has used is a
great inspiration for decades this line
comes from the mouth of the freaking
devil this is the great temptation
to live in fantasy to reject the world
that god has given us to reject the real
world as it actually is and close our
eyes and bury our heads in sand and just
live in our own fantasies that's
something that little children do when
they play pretend
now it's the adults who are teaching the
children who are telling them that the
pretend world is real life and that's
extraordinarily dangerous
i'm glad you like that clip now what i
need you to do is ring the bell
subscribe get all the notifications also
if you can head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you